[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy with a big
ego like peter quill's dad and this
video we're breaking down the trailer
leak for guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
shown at san diego comic-con over the
weekend footage of the trailer leaked
onto twitter after being a hall h
exclusive director james gunn said that
the teaser has all the shots in place
but that he doesn't want it released to
the public yet because it has unfinished
vfx in it gun took to twitter and said
that being shown once to a live audience
means that they can't pick it apart like
they would online and that's the best
look we have of it at the moment comes
from my uncle sitting and filming it on
his phone sorry your uncle it wasn't
nothing to do with me now throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
what happens in it the new characters
that appear and also what the plot of
the movie will center around if you
enjoy the video we'd love your three
thousand if you hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day by the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. now due to disney firing james
gunn there was a big issue with the
production of this movie the cast came
together and put out a message in an
attempt to get him rehired but gunn
ended up going over to dc in order to
film suicide squad
disney were unable to find a director to
fill his shoes and after taika would
hidey turned them down they ended up
bringing them back to complete the film
however this had severe consequences on
the production and originally this was
supposed to release before thor love and
thunder with it picking up after the
events of avengers end game however love
and thunder somewhat dealt with the
guardians though whether it worked is
completely dependent on your opinion of
the film they ended up leaving thor and
the upcoming film is very much going to
be centered around them continuing the
search for gamora who returns in this
new teaser from what your uncle could
gather the first look opens with the
guardians on board the benetto this is
the same crew that was in thor love and
thunder and it is possible that they've
come off just leaving the god of thunder
behind for the events of that movie now
we see a shot of nebula from behind and
electricity sparks up throughout the
ship peter says oh hell ravages and then
we cut to a wide shot of their ship
flying up close to the benetar according
to people at the event this meeting was
set up in advance but it's something
that quill wasn't privy to they pull
their guns on peter and nebula rushes
forward and says we have an appointment
there's a big surprise when gamora steps
forward and we discover that she's now
the person leading the ravages she's the
new manager
it's a beautiful morning at dunder
mifflin
as i like to call it great bratton keep
it running
now how nebula set this up i'm guessing
is because she and her sister ended up
standing side by side with each other
during the events of the final battle
and end game it was actually a deleted
scene where we saw gamora going off but
i'm guessing they kept this out of the
movie so there was some mystery over
whether she got dusted or not which yet
spoiler alert obviously wasn't gonna
happen now there is a possibility that
the pair kept a way to contact one
another but let me know your thoughts on
how they got in touch below gamora says
you're early and we get a long hold on
quills jaw dropping and she steps
forward looking sexy and that whole
green sexy should have done this with
she-hulk look to her that you know the
guy loves now from here we go to the
marvel studios logo and over the top of
this we can hear the song do you realize
by the flaming lips this song is a
fitting choice too as it has lyrics like
do you realize that you have the most
beautiful face do you realize we're
floating in space this is accompanied by
shots of the original gamora from the
original timeline and snippets of her
relationship with peter it's done in a
very similar way to the jane montage in
thor love and thunder and she spins
around into his arms similar to the
dance scene from the second guardian's
film peter says you were everything to
me but this is shot down by ravager
gamora who says that person wasn't me
she's holding a polaroid picture in her
hand i'm guessing that quill was trying
to convince her to love him we also have
kurtz of the pair wearing what look like
astronaut helmets and they're on a
planet with very low gravity there's a
team with them who are all in colourful
suits and it reminded me a lot of the
ones from the first jj abrams star trek
movie now speaking of suits we also know
that the guardians are going to be
wearing their comic book accurate
costumes at one point we see peter
wearing the red and blue uniform and
later on the rest of the guardians done
this as well this includes tracks which
will hopefully protect his very
sensitive nipples we also get clips
where mantis does a little dance and
nebula sees a large neon sign in an
unknown alien language that i'm not
really sure what it is find out what
language this is
broccoli
cloth near the star femur
next we get a shot of a baby raccoon
that cowers in terror as a hand goes
towards it this is obviously a young
rocket and the hand likely belongs to
the villain of the movie the high
evolutionary in case you don't know who
he is this is a character called herbert
wyndham who was born on earth namely
manchester after debuting in the mighty
thoughts sorry about that after debuting
in the mighty thor issue 134 herbert
took an interest in the works of
nathaniel essex aka mr sinister he
started carrying out experiments and
even built a device known as a genetic
accelerator that sped up the evolution
process he used this on rats in order to
advance our intelligence even though
that's not really how evolution works
but never mind what do you mean how does
it work well a rat is as evolved as you
are but moving on he slowly started to
experiment on animals and at one point
he even mixed a dalmatian with a
chimpanzee in order to create a dog
humanoid i'm guessing that this will be
pulled across to the movie as we know
that maria bakalova is voicing cosmo the
space dog and this will likely have been
experimented on by the big bad he of
course made rocket into what he is and
will likely discover his backstory with
the villain now we're unsure of what
he's after at the moment but my guess is
that he potentially wants rocket back
after a string of failures rocket is a
one of a kind and possibly he holds the
key as to how he can create more like
him now sadly i actually think that
rocket may end up dying in this movie he
doesn't have a very long life span and
with this being centered around his
birth we could also get his death too
either way it's going to be horrific
watching him getting cut apart and there
are shots in the teasers of sores that
look like tools the villain uses
speaking of origins we also get a shot
of a neighborhood in earth and it's
possible that quill could end up
returning there once more perhaps he
will come face to face with the family
that he left behind after he was
kidnapped by yondu and he might finally
confront the death of his mother there's
always a lot of chatter around the other
films as to why quill never really went
back to earth and he also left as quick
as he could after the events of endgame
you have to remember though that this is
a place of great trauma for him and just
like how you probably wouldn't be too
eager to return somewhere one of your
relatives died at he isn't either now
saying all this the scenes on earth
could also be linked to rocket and with
him being a raccoon he is a raccoon i
know i know he doesn't think he is but
with him being a raccoon he'll probably
come from our planet this might even be
how the movie opens as the last two
started on earth as well so it would
make sense to begin it all by showcasing
rocket's origins now we also get a shot
of will falter as adam warlock we last
left him being created at the end of
guardians vol 2 and in case you don't
know this is a character who is
massively tied to the infinity stones
normally he was a big adversary of
thanos but with the villain being dead
in the main timeline it's going to be
interesting to see what they do with him
he was also a major ally of pip the
troll who we were introduced to at the
end of the eternals he also has major
ties to the high evolutionary and he's
the character that gave him the name
warlock it's even possible that he
starts off working alongside him at the
beginning of the movie and then he
slowly ends up joining the guardians as
he realizes how bad his boss is don't
quote me on that yet okay i can just see
the high evolutionary having lots of
minions like him now he could also be
working for the sovereign who we saw
created him at the end of the last
guardians movie there's also a shot of
the monster from the start of that film
and we get a moment in which peter and
groot stand back-to-back firing guns
moments like this have been seen
throughout the guardians films at
several points and it's important to
bear in mind that groot is fully grown
at this point when we last left him he
was a teed but he's gonna be full size
for this film now james gunner said
their characters will die but not the
entire squad he says that just because
it's an ending it doesn't mean that
everyone will perish but expect to see
some of your favorite characters go out
in this movie along with rocket i'm
expecting drax to go too due to dave
batista confirming that this will be the
last time he plays the part his family
was of course killed by ronin thanos and
with them now being dead it makes sense
that this might be his last film the mcu
recently has also had a big focus on the
afterlife too so i'm expecting him to
potentially go in this movie just
reuniting with his family and we're good
baby now from what i could sorry from
what your uncle could see in the trailer
it looked like a really emotional
journey for the team and i'm very
excited to see what happens in the movie
it could end up being the best of the
trilogy and so far i think gunner's
knocking out the park on all the comic
book stuff he's worked on gonna be
interesting to see where they go with it
and obviously let me know your thoughts
below on what you want to see in the
movie we're running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers if you want some emails
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the ant-man quantum
mania trailer league which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
all the major details in that talk about
how kang ties into it so definitely go
head over there if you're curious about
that film if not then thank you for
singing through this video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]